casi exactamente un año después de su
dimisión hariri vuelve a ser el primer
ministro de líbano el hijo del ex primer
ministro rafic hariri regresa al poder
con la misión y la promesa de formar un
nuevo gobierno en medio de una de las
peores crisis en la historia del país
agradezco a mis compañeros
parlamentarios especialmente a los que
me nominaron para formar un gobierno
especialistas no partidistas cuya misión
es implementar las reformas económicas
financieras y administrativas contenidas
en el documento de iniciativa francés y
que los principales bloques
parlamentarios se han comprometido a
apoyar para su implementación
'francia lograr las reformas exigidas
por francia es la condición para que el
país reciba la ayuda internacional que
tanto necesita
hariri tuvo el apoyo de la mayoría en
las consultas parlamentarias el grupo
chiíta hezbollah dijo que no había
nominado a nadie pero aseguró que
buscaría facilitar el proceso de formar
gobierno
y la lealtad al bloque de la resistencia
hezbollah no nominó a nadie para primer
ministro pero contribuiremos a mantener
el clima positivo para lograr el
entendimiento necesario entre las partes
hariri heredé una crisis económica aún
más profunda que la que dejó hace 12
meses cuando la presión social en las
calles derrocó a su gobierno de
coalición ésta se vio agravada por la
crisis sanitaria del coronavirus y por
la explosión de casi 3000 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio que el pasado 4 de
agosto devastó el puerto de la ciudad de
beirut el hecho provocó la dimisión del
entonces primer ministro
hasan diab y posteriormente de su
sucesor mustafá adif tras no haber
podido formar un gabinete